so we all have bad seasons in life
and i had one in 2013. my marriage had
just ended and i was humiliated by that
failed commitment
my kids had left home for college or
were leaving
i grew up mostly in the conservative
movement but conservatism had changed so
i'd lost a lot of those friends too
and so what i did is i lived alone an
apartment
and i just worked if you open the
kitchen drawers where there should have
been utensils
there were post-it notes if you open the
other drawers where there should be
plates i had envelopes
uh i had work friends weekday friends
but i didn't have weekend friends
and so my weekends were these long
howling silences
and i was lonely and loneliness
unexpectedly came to me
in the form of um it felt like fear of
burning in my stomach
and it felt a little like drunkenness uh
just making bad decisions or just
fluidity a lack of solidity
and the painful part of that moment was
the awareness that
the emptiness in my apartment was just
reflective of the emptiness in myself
and that had fallen for some of the lies
that our culture tells us
the first lie is that career success is
fulfilling
i've had a fair bit of career success
and i found that helps me avoid the
shame i would feel
if i felt myself a failure but it hasn't
given me any positive good
the second lie is i can make myself
happy
that if i just win one more victory lose
15 pounds
do a little more yoga i'll get happy
and that's the lie of self-sufficiency
but as anybody on their deathbed will
tell you
the things that make people happy is the
deep relationships of life
the losing of self-sufficiency
the third lie is the lie of the
meritocracy
the message of the meritocracy is you
are what you accomplish
the myth of the meritocracy is you can
earn dignity by attaching yourself to
prestigious brands
the emotion of the meritocracy is
conditional love you can earn your way
to love
the anthropology of the meritocracies
you're not a soul to be purified
you're a set of skills to be maximized
and the evil of the meritocracy
is that people who've achieved a little
more than others are actually worth a
little more than others
and so the wages of sin are sin and my
sins were the sins of omission not
reaching out failing to show up for my
friends
evasion avoiding conflict and the weird
thing was that as i was falling in the
valley
it was a valley of disconnection a lot
of other people were doing that too
and that's sort of the secret to my
career a lot of the things that happened
to me are always happening to a lot of
other people
i'm a very average person with above
average communication skills
and so i was detached and at the same
time a lot of other people were detached
and isolated and fragmented from each
other 35 percent of americans over 45
are chronically lonely
only eight percent of americans report
having meaningful conversation with
their neighbors
only 32 percent of americans say they
trust their neighbors and only 18
percent of millennials
the fastest growing political parties
unaffiliated the fastest growing
religious movement is unaffiliated
depression rates are rising mental
health problems are rising
the suicide rate has risen 30 since 1999
for teen suicides over the last several
years the suicide rate
has risen by 70 percent 45 000 americans
kill themselves every year
72 000 die from opiate addictions life
expectancy
is falling not rising
so what i mean to tell you i came here i
flew out here to say that we have an
economic crisis we have an environmental
crisis we have political crisis
we also have a social and relational
crisis we're in the valley
we're fragmented from each other we've
got cascades of lies coming out of
washington we're in the valley
and so i've spent the last five years
how do you get out of a valley
and the greeks used to say you suffer
your way to wisdom
and from that dark period where i
started i've had a few realizations
the first is freedom sucks
economic freedom is okay political
freedom is great social freedom
sucks the unrooted man is the adrift man
the unrooted man is the unremembered man
because he's uncommitted to things
freedom is not a a river it's not an
ocean you want to swim in
it's wherever you want to get across so
you can commit and plant yourself on the
other side
the second thing i learned is when you
have one of those bad moments in life
you can either be broken or you can be
broken open
and we all know people who are broken
they've endured some pain or grief they
get smaller
that angry or resentful they lash out as
the saying is
pain that is not transformed gets
transmitted but other people are broken
open
suffering's greatest power is that it's
an interruption of life
it reminds you you're not the person you
thought you were the theologian paul
tillich said what suffering does
is it carves through the what you
thought was the floor of the basement of
your soul
and it carves through that revealing a
cavity below and it carves through that
revealing a cavity below
you realize there are depths of yourself
you never anticipated and only spiritual
and relational food will fill those
depths
and when you get down there you get out
of the head of the ego and you get into
the heart
the desiring heart the idea that what we
really yearn for is longing and love for
another
the kind of thing that louis bernier
described in his book captain
corelli's mandolin he had an old guy
talking to his daughter about his
relationship with his light wife
and the old guy says love itself is
whatever is left over when being in love
is burned away
and this book is both an art and a
fortunate accident
your mother and i had it we had roots
that grew towards each other underground
and when all the pretty blossoms had
fallen from our branches we discovered
that we are one tree and not two
that's what the heart yearns for the
second thing you discover
is your soul now i don't ask you to
believe in god or not believe in god but
i do ask you to believe that there's a
piece of you that has no shape
size color or weight but that gives you
infinite
big dignity and value rich and
successful people don't have more of
this than less successful people
slavery is wrong because it's an
obliteration of another soul
rape is not just an attack on a bunch of
physical molecules it's an attempt to
insult another person's soul
and what the soul does is it yearns for
righteousness
the heart burns for fusion with another
the soul yearns for righteousness
and that led to my third realization
which i borrowed from einstein
the problem you are you have is not
going to be solved at the level of
consciousness on which you created it
you would have to expand to a different
con level of consciousness
so what do you do well the first thing
you do you throw yourselves on your
friends and you have deeper
conversations than you ever had before
but the second thing you do you have to
go out alone into the wilderness
you go out into that place where there's
nobody there to perform and the ego has
nothing to do
and it crumbles and only then are you
capable of being loved
i have a friend who said um that when
her daughter was born she realized
that she loved her more than evolution
required
and i've always loved that because it
talks about the peace that's at the deep
of our self
our inexplicable care for one another
and when you touch that spot
you're ready to be rescued the hard
thing about when you're in the valley
is that you can't climb out somebody has
to reach in and pull you out
it happened to me i got luckily invited
over a house by a couple named kathy and
david
and they were uh they had a kid in the
dc public schools named santi santi had
a friend
who needed a place to stay cause his mom
had some health issues and then that kid
had a friend and that kid had a friend
and that kid had a friend
when he went to their house six years
ago i walk in the door there's like 25
around the kitchen table a whole bunch
sleeping on the downstairs in the
basement
i reach out to introduce myself to a kid
and he says
we don't really shake hands here we just
hug here
and i'm not the huggiest guy on the face
of the earth but i've been going back to
that home
every thursday night when i'm in town
and just hugging all those kids and why
they demand intimacy they demand that
you behave
in a way where you're showing all the
way up and they teach you a new way to
live which is the cure for all the ills
of our culture
which is a way of direct really putting
relationship first not as a word
just as a word but as a reality
and the beautiful thing is these
communities are everywhere i started
something called the aspen institute
called weave the social fabric this is
our logo here
and we go pop into a place and we find
we verse anywhere everywhere
we find people like aisha butler who
grew up in um
who lived in chicago in englewood in a
tough neighborhood and she was about to
move because it was so dangerous
and she looked across the street and she
saw two little girls playing an empty
lot
with broken bottles and she turned to
her husband and she said we're not
leaving
we're not going to be just another
family that abandoned that and she
googled volunteer in
englewood and now she runs rage the big
community organization there
some of these people have had tough
valleys
i met a woman named sarah in ohio who
came home from an antiquing trip
and found that her husband had killed
himself then and their two kids
she now runs a pharma free pharmacy she
volunteers in the community she helps
women cope with violence she teaches
she told me i grew from this experience
because i was angry
i was gonna fight back what against what
he tried to do to me by making a
difference in the world
see he didn't kill him to kill me my
response to him is whatever you meant to
do to
me screw you you're not gonna do it
these weavers are not living an
individualistic life
they're living a relationship they have
a different set of values they have
moral motivations
they have vocational certitude they have
planted themselves down i met a guy in
youngstown ohio just held up a sign
in the town square defend youngstown
they have radical mutuality
and they are geniuses that relationship
there's a woman named mary gordon who
runs something called roots of empathy
and what they do is they take a bunch of
kids in eighth grade class
they put a mom and an infant and then
the kids the students have to guess what
the infant is thinking to teach empathy
there's one kid in a class who um was
bigger than the rest because he'd been
held back
been through the foster care system seen
his mom get killed
and he wanted to hold the baby and the
mom was nervous because he looked big
and scary
but she let this kid darren hold the
baby he held it and he was great with it
he gave the baby back and started asking
questions about parenthood
and his final question was if nobody has
ever loved you do you think you can be a
good father
and so what roots of empathy does is
they reach down and they grab people out
of the valley
and that's what weavers are doing
some of them switch jobs they some of
them stay in their same jobs
but one of the things they have an
intensity to them i read this
e.o wilson wrote a great book called
naturalist about his
his um uh his childhood and when he was
seven his parents were divorcing
uh and they sent him to paradise beach
in north florida
and he'd never seen the ocean before and
he'd never seen a jellyfish before he
wrote the creature was astonishing
it existed beyond my imagination he was
sitting on the dock one day and he saw
a stingray float beneath his feet and he
at that moment a naturalist was born in
the awe and wonder
and he makes this observation that when
your child
you see animals at twice the size as you
do as an adult
and that has always impressed me because
it's a what we want as kids
is that moral intensity to be totally
given ourselves over to something
and to find that level of vocation and
when you were around these weavers
they see other people at twice the size
as normal vehicle they see deeper into
them and what they see
is joy on the first mountain of our life
when we're shooting for our career
we uh we shoot for happiness and
happiness is good it's it's the
expansion of self
you win a victory you have you uh
get a promotion your team wins the super
bowl you're happy
joy is not the expansion of self it's
the dissolving of self
it's the moment when the skin barrier
disappears between a mother and her
child it's the moment when a naturalist
feels just free in nature
it's the moment where you're so lost in
your work or a cause you have totally
self-forgotten
and joy is a better thing to aim for
than happiness i collect
passages of joy of people when they lose
it one of my favorite is from zadie
smith
in 1999 she was in a london nightclub
looking for her friends wondering where
a handbag was
and suddenly as she writes a real thin
man with enormous eyes reached across a
sea of bodies from my hand
he kept asking me the same thing over
and over are you feeling it
my ridiculous heels were killing me i
was terrified i might die
yet i felt simultaneously overwhelmed
with the light that can i kick it
should happen playing on this precise
moment in the history world on the sound
system
and it was now morphing into teen spirit
i took the man's hand
the top of my head blew away we danced
we danced
we gave ourselves up to joy and so what
i'm trying to describe is two different
live
mindsets a first mountain mindset which
is about
individual happiness and career success
and it's a good mindset i have nothing
against it
but we're in a national valley because
we don't have the other mindset to
balance it
we no longer feel good about ourselves
as a people we've lost our defining
faith in our future
we don't see each other deeply we don't
treat each other as well
we need a lot of changes we need
economic change and environmental change
but we also need a cultural and
relational revolution
we need to name the language of a
recovered society
and to me the weavers have found that
language
my theory of social change is that
society changes when a small group of
people find a better way to live
and the rest of us copy them and these
weavers have found a better way to live
and you don't have to theorize about it
they're out there as community
builders all around the country we just
have to shift our lives a little
so we can say well i'm a weaver we're a
weaver
and if we do that the hole inside
ourselves gets filled
but more important the social unity gets
repaired thank you very much